today we're going to cancel uh book
burners
now this should be a cancellation that
i'm doing in 1930s germany not
modern america but as always those who
allegedly
hate fascism have a funny habit of
copying its
methods uh and it's happening yet again
so here's the newsweek report it says
a new tick tock trend has enrage has
emerged this week as former harry potter
fans protest author jk rowling's widely
criticized views on trans people
by burning copies of her books uh one
video posted by a tick-tock
user shows a number of harry potter
books being placed on a burning pyre
um you have to stop using death of the
author as an excuse to have your cake
and eat it too the voice over says
while the reader's perspective is an
important part of interpretation and
meaning it is impossible to completely
divorce a work from its creator
the voiceover continues the positive
impact that jk rowling's work had on
millions of readers
does not negate how her hateful lobbying
has affected the trans community
this doesn't even touch on the harmful
fat phobia
oh she's fat phobic now too i hadn't
heard about that racism
and valorization of supremacists and
child abusers in her most famous work
the video ends with a message your love
of harry potter is not more important
than the lives of trans women well
there's a false dichotomy if you've ever
heard one in my life
you have to choose between those two
things either harry potter or
quote-unquote trans women you can't you
have to choose between them
now um and you can see in the video here
one of the book burnings happening
um now why are people mad at jk rowling
well this goes back of course to the
controversy that rowling stirred up
months ago when
she first came out as a believer in
biology this is a very stressful and
dangerous thing for any celebrity
or anyone who runs in left-wing circles
to be exposed as a biology believer can
have serious consequences in their lives
for it to be found out that you believe
that men have penises
um this is the kind of thing that can
ruin your life
jk rowling that's she's discovered that
ever since she admitted publicly that
men had penises
many of her previous fans have had this
vendetta against her
now this was ramped up this week when it
was reported by pink news
which is one of the most atrocious and
dishonest left-wing rags
in existence and there's a lot of
competition for that title uh it was
reported that jk rowling
has written a transphobic novel about a
man who dresses as a woman to kill his
victims
and their tweet about it which you can
see right here has 35
000 retweets with thousands of people
reacting in horror
based on a headline about a book that
they haven't read
and the irony is that many of these
people who are who are
freaking out about this book they
haven't read these are the same ones who
said that you can't judge the netflix
movie cuties without watching it
now of course you could try to argue
that the knife cuts the other way too
and i said you can judge cuties without
watching it but here i'm saying you
can't you can't judge the book without
reading it
doesn't that make me a hypocrite no it
doesn't and i'll tell you why
here's the difference cuties is a movie
which means the scenes with the young
girls in sexually compromised positions
that actually happened they really did
that
the filmmakers really had young children
act that way and they filmed it
so you can absolutely object to filming
11 year olds twerking
without watching 11 year olds twerk the
same way you could object to
someone drowning puppies without
watching them do it a book is different
nobody is hurt in the making of a book
it's entirely fiction it's just
words so you can object to certain acts
being committed against children
without seeing the acts but it doesn't
make sense to object to words being
written
without first understanding the context
of those words
hopefully the distinction there is clear
and i don't need to dwell on it anymore
now other media outlets have jumped on
the pile
the daily telegraph for example reported
that rowling's book
is about a transvestite killer and the
moral of the story is
never trust a man in a dress
and i think this is from someone who
also didn't read it but they're telling
you what the moral of the story is
now personally i think that's a fine
moral
and good advice and in fact if you call
that statement never trust a man in
address
transphobic then you're saying that the
person in the dress
is a man so wouldn't you be the
transphobic one then by your logic
um in any case it turns out that this is
all being blown out of proportion
unsurprisingly madeline kearns has a
piece about this in the national review
this is what she says according to nick
cohen who reviewed troubled blood that's
the name of the book
after actually reading the book
transvestitism barely features in the
plot
um when it and when it does nothing is
made of the fact that the killer wears a
wig and a women's woman's coat not a
dress
as a disguise when approaching one of
his victims cohen describes the work
which is the fifth installment in
rowling's
uh komoron strike crime series as a 900
page
novel that is dickensian in its scope
and gallery of characters it tells the
tale of
strike and his business partner robin
ellicott who are hired by a middle-aged
woman and to investigate the
disappearance
of her mother in the 1970s a mother a
character called dennis creed is
investigated because he was thought
guilty at the time
but a good dozen other suspects are also
investigated he concludes
you have to search hard to find a
justification for the belief that the
book's moral
seems to be never trust a man in a dress
so it's all bogus and in fact there's
nothing new or strange about a story
like this featuring a dude
dressing in women's clothes to kill
someone psycho
alfred hitchcock has similar themes
silence silence of the lambs
has themes in that ballpark as well of
course i wouldn't expect these book
burners to know that because they've
only read
one book in their lives harry potter and
even their knowledge of film goes back
no further than about 2006.
all of this and when i look at the
modern left in general
it brings to mind a quote from c.s lewis
in his memoir
surprised by joy and he said a young man
who wishes to remain a sound
atheist cannot be too careful of his
reading there are traps everywhere
that's the quote and what he meant is
that for him
atheism seems to be a tenuous and
fragile world view which can be easily
blown apart and so must be preserved and
protected by among other things
being very selective in what you choose
to expose yourself to
i think this applies even more so to
modern leftism though atheism and modern
leftism of course are not unrelated
but this is why we're seeing you know
book burning popping up again because
knowledge information diversity of
thought differing viewpoints
these are a mortal threat to a worldview
that cannot withstand the pressure
cannot stand up against the scrutiny all
it can do is shout you down
shut you up burn your book cancel you
burn a building throw a rock at you so
very often it has physical responses to
intellectual challenges
and that's because it's intellectual
arsenal is empty
and you definitely know that's the case
for you if you find yourself burning a
book
and that's why book burners today are
cancelled
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content